hello everyone and welcome to another
game of round for tiebreaks of the 2019
FIBA World Cup
it's Tingler and vs. kiddo Alex Sink Oh
Alex anko is well the biggest surprise
of the Phaedo World Cup he's the only
below 2700 player that lasted this far
into the competition and now he has to
face King ding so the to class begins
between the do of the two of them ended
in a draw and then now we entered the
rapid section this is the first game of
the rapids let's enjoy it as it's just
well it's a really weird game but also a
very enjoyable one and also here is a
nice photo of the two of them it's not
from this game it's from the classical
one the forest by Kyra mercury official
photographer of the fede World Cup 2019
so let's just enjoy it for a second
nothing out of the ordinary on the board
but we will get in the mood for the game
so there we have it now let's check out
the game with the white pieces ding
opens with c4 the English opening with E
5 by Alex & Co and now g3 preparing the
Finca to the light square Bishop with
Knight to c6 Knight to c3 and now g6
black also wants the finger of his dark
square Bishop Bishop to g2 and now v6
with III biding preparing d4 and now
Bishop to g7 with Knight to e2 now
preparing the castle and h5 and here
ding replies with h4 with Bishop to e6
and now b3 we have B 3 is a new move
already so already as a move 8 this is
not a completely new game which is
always very enjoyable with Knight to f6
preparing the castle in the now d4 you
have to react to this as the threat is d
5 you would win material if this would
happen so it captures on d4 e captures
and now the threat remains so Alex ankle
goes Bishop to g4 pins the night and now
d5 no longer a threat
we have castles by dink and now Queen to
d7 connecting well everything now the
King can also go to the Queen side if
Alex and Cody side so Bishop to g5
biding and now Cass linking
side by Alex and Co with Queen to d2 now
developing the Queen connecting rooks
also worshiped age six is now possible
if everything wants it and rook 8e8
being also breaking brings his rook into
the game we have rook 81 and now a six
so here
ding plays d5 and this is one of those
moments you know how we always say that
the strongest move is with the knight
back well this is one of those cases
nice the e7 is what you have to play
here but here Alex and Co played nicely
5 and believe it or not even though it's
only moved 15 black is completely lost
here which is just amazing no one would
expect this but well Dean would expect
it so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find why is Knight to e5 the
losing move for black well I give you a
couple of seconds and you know if you
need more than a couple of seconds you
know don't feel bad as Alex & Co
completely missed this
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on punishing such a
you know move with the knight not back
and for those who just wanna enjoy the
show Bishop captures on f6 that's that's
what wins the game because now if you
play Bishop captures on f6 white plays
f4 and the knight is trap the Knight has
nowhere to go all of the squares here
are taken and the knight has nowhere to
go it's just incredible that so early in
the game we would see a trapped piece so
after Bishop captures an f6 of course
Alex saying consolidate the bishop
captures therefore traps a piece he
decided to play Bishop captures on e2
not threatening to capture the roof but
the ding says no problem he says a
Bishop captures on g7 now attacking
blacks rook on f8 and here Bishop
captures on f1 now going even after the
bishop on g2 but all of this doesn't
work it's not only that the knight was
trapped if the bishop on f6 was captured
this also doesn't work for Alex Sink oh
and now once again pause the video and
try to find the absolute best move for
white for well well I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you were able to
do it congratulations you are in
and threatener of mate on h8 still you
know the rhyme is not attended but it
seems like every other video there's a
maid threatened h8 Queen to h6 there it
is so for those of you who just wanted
to enjoy the show now the thread is of
course Queen - h8 make and you have to
prevent this f6 or f5 you have to make
room for the king Alex and Co played f6
and now comes Queen to h8 check King to
f7 and now Bishop captures on f8 the
thread is now Queen to g7 mate as the
pawn covers the e6 square this is also
what I will be using for the thumbnail
and now well if you play rook captures
on f8 it is possible but then you get
the Queen h7 check King te 8 and now
Queen captures on g6 check King to d8
and now first you're going to go after
the rook and the once the rook is
defended let's say Queen f7 now you just
pick up the Bishop and you are just up a
piece in a much better position
this is unplayable for black so Alex &
Co said ok Knight to f3 check at least
I'm gonna pick up the rock on e1
ding said okay Bishop captures on f3 we
have rook captures anyone and now there
are a lot of good moves for white here
but being chooses a well Bishop to h6 he
doesn't want to force anything with
Queen TG 7 this is just it works out
just as nicely and now the problem is
that although you have some discoveries
you don't have any nasty discoveries
because all of these pieces are on dark
squares you could grab a pawn I mean
yeah it's not really a a position where
you want to grab a pawn and also if just
there should be to check the King King
g2 will defend the bishop on f3 so it's
not a problem
Bishop to d3 check was played but now
keep the h2 biding and now keeper Queen
to e7 and here again your upper piece a
lot of moves are possible but the ding
finds the absolute best one
he plays c5 and it was in this position
that kiddo alex angkor resigned the game
now why did he resign well because he's
down a piece but also because c5 is such
a powerful move for example if you
ignore the c5 move but what are you
gonna play you don't really have a good
move let's say you play something like
Bishop to f5 and allow white some
initiative
well then comes Queen g7 check you're
going to
King d8 queen g8 check Kings a d7 sorry
King 37 and now weld upon isn't c5 just
c6 check captures captures and this is
now mate as the Queen covers everything
here so this is one of the well nice
things about having your opponent's e5
and on the other hand if you capture the
pawn then things idea was d6 just giving
up two points for Bishop to b5 check and
this will of course be deadly let's say
Queen captures Bishop d5 check now you
have to block with the rook rook e6 now
we're gonna eliminate the b7 pawn just
so black cannot kick her bishop away
with a move like c6 and after rook e8
you're gonna go back Queen g7 check King
e6 you're gonna go back up to d5 check
King to f5 and now well this is just
complete madness Bishop to f7 go after
the rook and the g6 pawn once the rook
moves you're gonna go captures with
check King e5 you're gonna go captures
with check King before and now after 91
your king is on d4 you don't have any
squares to go to this is just well not
that but you're getting mated and very
very soon so Alex and consorted after c5
there was no more point in playing this
game at least this is Game one of the
rapid section and he will have the white
pieces in the next game so maybe he can
maybe he can defend well maybe he can
win against dink with the white pieces
but since I already mentioned in the
previous video that's being advanced and
I will show it once again so these are
the standings in the in the next game
well Alex & Co was unable to beat it in
with the white pieces ding also won that
game with the black pieces and of course
he advanced now these are the standings
if you maybe missed it in the previous
round ding will face Alexander agree
shocked Nikita fatigued oval face you
yongi
Geoffrey Xuan eliminated Duda will face
tomorrow job of we eliminate the chakra
mummy yar off and the maxi Marshall de
Graaff who eliminated Peter Svidler will
face 11 Oregon who eliminated look Wong
William sir that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it really a wonderful
miniature and it's it's really it's
beyond imagine
that that such a piece blunder can occur
in the World Cup in the game between
well and almost 2700 and and dinkler and
just just incredible
but always when you have an option of
going with the night back do check if
that's a better move than going with the
night forward yeah it usually is so once
again I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Vivek padmanaban Muhammad
barber kallio Robin we're Hector
Coronado and Robin veer once again for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the 3d World
Cup checking up in your suggestions and
so on so thank you all I will see soon
and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday